we're joined now to you know talk talk
about this horrific day what can we
learn from what we know so far and can
these schools really be safer in the
face of these threats of mass shootings
former LAPD detective Mark Fuhrman is
with us along with Randi Sutton a former
Las Vegas police officer gentlemen it's
good to see you and another awful night
mark let's start with you
you've been taking this all in today
what are your thoughts well Laura when
you look at this since Columbine it
seems that public schools have grappled
with security in a lot of ways and
they've come up with a lot of scenarios
for lockdown procedures and dealing with
the police that are about to approach in
an active shooter situation but we have
to look at the things that are coming up
once again gun control comes up once
again mental illness we're not going to
stop mental illness we're not going to
get rid of the second Amendment but we
can harden a target we can lock down
schools we can have some type of
electronic admission we can't have metal
detectors we can make the kids safe so
the shooter just can't walk into the
school anytime he pleases and that's
what happens every single time in one of
these shootings Randi I was at my kids
school today and it's so weird because I
was buzzed in and every time I'm buzzed
into a school to visit a friend or my
own kids I always think about these
things that I went through my mind today
it's easy to get into most schools right
if you could kill a secure it so we
could kill a security guard they force
someone to buzz you and then you're in I
mean what can you really do you can't as
previous guests said in Hannity show you
can't turn a school into a prison and so
then people get locked into classrooms
and is that a good idea given the fact
that then you're a target in a classroom
I mean I'm not an expert on this you are
Randy no you know you you you said it
very well that that we can't make we
can't make these schools into a prison
however we can target hardened and there
was there's a very wise man that once
said if it's predictable its preventable
and unfortunately we have now found that
that school shooting
are predictable so we have to discover
the the ways that we can target hard in
these schools and and at least give
these these children and these teachers
and staff members a chance now there
there's clearly a correlation here that
we have seen tonight that there was
because of training many many lives that
were saved so so that's a positive but
we have to look at a way to prevent what
is predictable a mark let's go back to
you on this we found out that he was
denied entrance to the school campus not
so long ago when he was carrying a
backpack he had reportedly made threats
some ingest some others perhaps not
against other students by all accounts
he was socially ostracized his mother
died last year he was an adopted young
man his tives his family in the area
obviously and but his mother died he
followed the Iraqi resistance online and
Iraq fighters Syrian resistance in Iraq
fighters according to trace Gallagher
we're learning more about his profile
and obviously the photos on social media
of him with various knives various guns
asking about long gun background checks
from particular ammunition so he was
getting ready for something well you
know these are clues and there's a
thousand people that people are that can
name right now that are watching this
show of yours right now that say he fits
that profile so if we can profile and we
can actually target these people and
actually notify somebody is there really
an agency that's going to do anything
you know on Sean Hannity's show he
brought up retired cops and retired
military being on campus you know I
understand what he's saying but I
disagree I think you need to make school
security a specialty you need to make it
a specialty just like terrorism you need
to have young officers that are
motivated and in the beginning of their
career that are sharp and actually are
really dedicated to the long reign
of being in this type of profession in
school security because our youth are
some of the most important people in the
country and yet it seems that we secure
them the least and Randy back to you
given the fact that they knew he was
very troubled and there are a lot of
kids who are troubled a lot of kids have
broken homes that come from broken homes
they seem like they have a predilection
to violence or anger repressed anger
ostracized alone he had very few friends
apparently at the school we haven't
found one friend or someone who even
considered himself at at real
acquaintances of him so those do kind of
tick off a lot and mark you've been on
this for a lot of these school shooters
so given that they knew all this about
him I'm not saying they should have
known who's gonna shoot but is there any
interventions that you can do either
either at the home with him that could
have prevented this I mean he was
expelled from the school for obvious
reasons there's gonna what's the once
the the autopsy of this individual is
done when I say autopsy I'm talking
about a psychological autopsy is done
they're gonna discover that there were a
number of key factors that would that
would have warned the sent red flags up
all over the place but and and and these
things are very nothing happens in a
vacuum there are people that that are
already have spoken that knew that this
guy had predilections for violence and
that he was off as you know he was he
was making these these comments he was
he was showing basically I think his
cards in advance but I want to talk
about something that mark just spoke
about and no Israel in the in the 70s
dealt with the the schools being
targeted by terrorists and they had they
lived through unfortunately the the
murders of a number of school children
and they have stopped it and you know
what Laura we can to mark finally on
this the ar-15 looks like was his weapon
of choice that was involved in the San
Bernardino shooting Sandy Hook the pulse
nightclub and so you already see the
push about re-examining the ar-15 it
tell us a little bit about that weapon
40% of Floridians have firearms air 15
one of the most popular firearms in the
United States but that clearly is being
targeted by the anti-gun folks tonight
well Laura it's it's considered is
called the m4 platform and it's based on
the ar-15 and yes there's a lot of them
and most of them are used legally if a
suspect chooses that weapon and you take
that weapon away they've been making
weapons since about 1908 that are
automatic fired weapons that can you
know deliver just as much firepower and
almost as fast as an ar-15 in the hands
of a competent person you don't even
need that you need something that is
very almost an antique weapon to do the
same amount of damage so it's it's in
the hands of a skilled person an ar-15
makes up for that a little bit but it is
not the reason that this occurred the
reason that this occurred is not only a
mental illness its security it's not not
having a hardened target and actually
not anybody paying attention to all the
flags well thank you gentlemen on a very
difficult night for just terrific
analysis of this horrific situation